welcome to this video and this is a nice
one and playing grandmaster a reputation
and this is Fabiano Kiwanis of the world
number three if I'm not mistaken at the
moment he's playing um he and the five
minute Poland ICC displaying the
regularly for a while but I never had
never was lucky enough to get one of
those interesting games okay you see
this rated about 2700 it is having the
Spanish flag so probably there's just
some tournament in Spain I don't know
okay so I have played d6 a six and so on
all this is geared towards this this
push this g5 push and I'm hoping them
this is one of the positions where you
can actually do that try to fight for
play on the dark squares I could
actually give the check yeah let's get a
check getting the Queen's of a certain
the shank is certainly good for black
not an advantage but I mean something
that black should should aim for
so it's a position where white has some
a central edge in exchange for the
bishop pair so black at least
theoretically should try to open up the
position it's not so easy though because
he's got this big Center and rook g1 is
also a good news
okay yeah my my dears kilo castles and
then mm yeah should I play d5 an
interesting question you know on d5 I
think he's going to play f5
okay I know that all that and hope that
this at the end we'll just open up lines
for my former bishops Bishop somewhere
yeah we should be a display nerd explain
either sticks
maybe f5 if he takes up a song Bishop h8
and I'm probably getting this back ok
I'm already far behind the clock behind
on the clock so it didn't take this
probably means that this idea wasn't
wasn't so terrible
ok should I take off play d5 d5 looks
like it's closest to the position but
Bishop c4 has a good plan
yeah let's get close it's not I'm not
such a such a big deal
maybe Knight h5 to have six this could
be could be an issue
I cannot take then he's got 95
check yeah kingi six runs into turn idea
form so let's let's better retreat him
yeah their five porn and the bishop here
this is so great a great combination
that spells disaster
so he wants to go to g3 understandably
we need to get this this bloody Bishop
to a fade it's probably beyond repair
anyway but still
check
yeah he's complaining 6 or just take
which isn't bad at all yeah disappoints
the only kind of counter play it's not
not enough but
I hope the agent okay
black resigns yeah this was pretty much
a one-way street at some point very
difficult I'm not sure how bad this is
yeah maybe he can take but okay he
didn't and here around here I need to
improve I think around him yeah probably
taking us is bad 97 is stronger yeah I
97 is much stronger
and the other thing is if you look at
this I should my not dismiss this would
have been interesting the the bishop on
h8 really got stuck and he won against
this Bishop this isn't so clear if he
goes to night age five no I can just
exchange and maybe I can even take and
activate this bishop in case he
recaptures with the D pawn yeah this is
probably the way to go in the game see
for now I need to play 97 but after
taking I mean I'm in bad shape
and he played this very nicely yeah yeah
this is just just very excellent and
straightforward play
I cannot cannot do anything else check
and now I have got this this Ted Bishop
and did this pawn it's just it's just
it's just gone and this is just good
technique but to check to g6 I have
absolutely no plan here I mean in the
sense that there isn't any I think not
like I didn't find a plan that is new
plan and okay he has got multiple
vincent he found one of them yeah this
happens if you play against a really
really strong player like two mistakes
and and you're toast yeah this is also
much tougher I am because let's say he
cannot really take because of this at
least it's not so effective and this
means he he doesn't get this active
Bishop quickly probably you know this is
probably still good but it's tougher
it's tougher than the game and the game
he
timing him and even this immediate
threat him
yeah very nicely played back thanks for
watching